from the post Malone and we have the
story Greg Gutfeld jokes Tucker Carlson
Carlson will run for president after
leaving Fox News granted he's joking he
said in 2024 what would be Susan Rice
versus Tucker Carlson and then you can
see that uh post Millennials got some
some what is that CSS code or something
that's just I'm going to highlight that
so that Libby's season goes crap Libby
what are you doing
The Godfather host made the comments
while appearing on Fox News The Five
alongside other Fox personalities the
panelists then brought up Democrat Susan
Rice President Biden's White House
domestic policy advisor who announced
she would be departing from a post on
Monday which had the Fox News
personalities predicting she would be a
contender in the 2024 election so he's
kind of joking but kind of not and I'm
wondering now somebody so the
conversation is is Trump Carlson 2024
but then there was a question I don't
know if it was you were asking it Adrian
DeSantis Carlson maybe that'd be a
ticket now here's the thing if the
Republican primary is between DeSantis
Carlson and Trump I'm a happy man right
if these are the kinds of candidates
we're getting because look at what it
was back in 2016. right Trump was the
only person who had politics besides I
guess Ron Paul we almost had sorry we
were very very close to fixing the
system and getting everything done right
all we have had for for years and years
decades are these boring establishment
candidates who just want to go along
with whatever we got that name of jab
with the entire map turning yellow I
don't disagree that it we should have
picked Jeff but we missed our
opportunity but it's be real to be real
Jeb is The One That Got Away there's no
getting Jeb back he's gone he's out of
our life I thought where you were going
with that was being serious about it
because honestly we almost got Trump
versus Bernie in 2010 oh right and and
yes I mean I I like it's it's still
amazing to me that we didn't get burned
burning was well like the front runner
Bernie was leading the charge against
the Democrat establishment and then got
to the DNC stopped turned around and
said you are all trespassing and you
must leave so it was like he let
everyone there and then just immediately
joined with Hillary and then he was like
if you want to be a millionaire you
write a book yeah but that's 2016 yeah
in 2020 he was I mean they went to
Nevada and I read about this uncovered
MSNBC Joy read people like that went
after Bernie Sanders when at Chris
Matthews when he was still back on the
air before he got me too they they went
completely all in on Joe Biden because
they needed to stop him in the same way
that mayor peed and Amy Klobuchar drop
dropped out yeah and endorsed by right
before super Tuesday I mean these people
were contenders I mean not huge
contenders but they they all galvanized
in the same way the politics did the the
music this is the best thing this is the
best thing hear this my friends so boo
to judge drops out of the race endorses
Joe Biden why it's obvious they were
siphoning away votes they were breaking
the the moderate vote and Bernie was
then taking the lead if Klobuchar Buddha
judge if they drop out and endorse Biden
Biden gets a big bump beats Bernie
Sanders likely what happens is that Joe
Biden goes to them and says I will make
you a deal
Pete you drop out we got a job for you
he says okay you got it how about
something cushy a do-nothing job like
Transportation secretary you don't have
to pay attention
and Pete's like so you're saying I don't
have to do any work it's like what's the
job you look at a screen and some trucks
driving by you don't gotta do anything
nobody pays attention when's the last
time you saw a transportation secretary
on TV and now look where we are yeah but
for real that's probably what happened
oh yeah yeah so he drops out they're
like it's the job is yours and then a
train blows up and he's like not there
well I thought this must be an easy job
what's going on I also think this is not
um necessarily in original Insight other
people have said this this is something
Dave Smith has said before too but there
is something to be said about the fact
that the way Bernie treated the people
he was running against didn't really
match his rhetoric about the fact that
they were screwing the working class
right Trump's treatment of other
political leaders matches his rhetoric
on how he feels about political leaders
he's not nice to them and then Bernie
Sanders gets on stage he's like oh well
of course I love these people they are
my best friends and it's like okay well
you're not exactly selling to people
that you genuinely want to fight them
but also what did Bernie do he endorsed
Hillary and then he endorsed Joe Biden
so they knew they could take it from him
Donald Trump wasn't going to endorse any
other Republican if he didn't get that
right now so they knew they had to give
it to him the way I like to describe it
is there's a big Ivory Tower and Bernie
comes from the left up the hill with a
bunch of angry you know leftists and
then Trump comes up on the right with a
bunch of angry angry right-wingers and
then they're both standing on each side
and the elites are looking down like oh
what do we do what do we do and then
Bernie is like I am humbly asking that
you open the door and then they're like
okay and then knock knock and then
Bernie's like I'm gonna go inside real
quick and uh and work something out with
them and then next thing you know
Bernie's sticking us out the window
being like get out of here good but then
Trump kicks the door in and just starts
rampaging through the Halls like a bull
it's an Insurrection and they're
freaking out they're like it's
interaction it's interaction uh help us
help us and then Tucker Carlson releases
the security camera footage of what
happened after they broke down the door
of the castle and then Bernie's running
away with them yeah it's like like the
the Bernie becoming a millionaire is the
perfect example of what's wrong with
Bernie Sanders yes when when he has what
four houses three three houses yeah what
was his recent book his book was like
why it's wrong to be a millionaire or
something like that you know it's like
he stopped saying millionaires when he
became one right yeah the Millionaires
and the billionaires then he became a
millionaire and he stopped saying it and
I'm like Bernie you don't have to stop
saying it because you're rich there are
people with 999 million dollars you can
make that point but he's a he's a
grifter yeah so that was it that we'll
talk about a letdown well he said look
when you write a best-selling book you
could be a millionaire too as if the
publishing industry doesn't follow the
same mechanisms that socialists
criticize and other Industries like well
what about the logger who cut down the
trees that was that were then turned
into the paper Bernie and what about the
people operating the printing press like
why don't they all get an equal share in
the profits of your book The World
socialist website called Bernie Sanders
a nationalist capitalist
no joke what is it the world socialist
website called Bernie Sanders a
nationalist capitalist wow because he's
in favor of capital capitalist
structures even though he's Fair he's
far left he still is talking about
Capital structures and he wants to
secure the borders so that he can
protect workers he had a quote at a
rally where he said we can't have open
borders my God the people they would all
just flood in right and then they were
like how dare you you nationalist
capitalists didn't he call it a Koch
brother scheme yeah in 28 2015. yeah
he's ever been born as a Koch brothers
proposal to get cheap labor I mean it's
it's amazing to me how Democrats
claim they're in favor of unions they
know that a scab entering into a
workplace when they're not a member of a
union could drive wages down but when
you place that or abstract that onto a
national scale they're unwilling to
recognize that that's true wait a minute
what about like the literal Union that
we call like the United States of
America don't you think someone entering
into our Union who isn't playing by the
same rules and isn't becoming a
registered member taking jobs might
lower average wages for the people who
are already in the country but for
whatever reason the principal stops
operating there yeah that's why
immigration honestly was the biggest
issue you know cross party for Donald
Trump I think but honestly like I hate
to go back to Tucker again but another
thing he said it's like even Trump gets
in there and yes he was totally
anti-establishment anti-elite that's
what got him in but Tucker told me for
the book that you know he gets in there
and he puts Steve mnuchin in treasury or
or a lot of the people that he put in
these positions a lot of the things that
he said and this is some of the things
that Tucker has been critical of trump
about more recently is when he actually
got in there you still you okay you
drain the swamp all that and yes he was
he said the right things but ultimately
how did he govern there's still some
criticism there and actually I think
like a candidate who really wants to go
after Trump for from the right like at
DeSantis I don't know if he's got it in
him would be to say well you got in
there kovid whatever else you know
border did you actually do what you said
you were going to do and and break up
the the actual you know Elite
establishment that you that you claim to
be doing somewhat but only a little bit
yeah not enough right not enough but uh
enough to where I'm looking forward to
Trump getting revenge schedule F yeah
and and I think what really makes this
work is if Trump just had his term and
then lost and there was no Russia gate
and there was no impeachment and all
that stuff
I wouldn't know if I'd be so enthused
I'd be like well you know we had Trump
like maybe DeSantis is going to work out
I don't know but the fact that they've
they've gone after Trump so heavy
heavy-handedly handedly the fact that
they're trying to indict him in three
different jurisdictions I'm like okay so
now we're gonna get that equal and
opposite reaction that I'm excited about
they they came at trump super hard and
he's ready to come back schedule a left
lock down take it I love it yeah yeah
I'm ready for it I mean the 100 Biden
laptop story just like the icing on the
cake of the Trump uh you know presidency
I mean the way that the media you know
in collusion with tech companies
inclusion with the FBI as we now know
thanks to the Twitter files lock down
that story and the fact that it has
become so obvious that it was true I
mean it was obviously it was true when
it actually was being written but the
way the media covered it and then what
we now know has just made that just so
clear to everyone that if if that moved
a few thousand votes a couple you know
30 000 votes that would have made an
enormous difference in the election and
the fact that they did that that will
stick with people I think and that you
know it's it's a media story but it's a
politic story
yeah uh there there was a poll done on
that as well a very large percentage of
Biden voters had absolutely no idea
about the the hunter Biden story and
about 10 of people who voted for bidenu
reserve it said if they had known about
the hunter Biden laptop story they would
not have voted for Joe yeah I think it
was like 16 but that was enough to have
swung the election depending on where
those orders were thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time